There have been scenes of jubilation in Mali,
after France said it would begin to pull its
troops out of the West African country.
France has helped in the struggle against
radical Islamic militias for nine years - until
relations with Mali's military leaders turned
sour.
Paris objects to their alleged hiring of a
Russian mercenary group to fight the jihadists.
But for now there's a sense of relief in Bamako.
In the streets of Bamako, Malians wave brooms
and sweep away ash - symbolising the departure
of French troops after nearly a decade.
French President Emmanuel Macron announced
the withdrawal of anti-jihadist forces on
Thursday - after months of escalating tensions
with Mali's military leaders.
But his inital timeline of four to six months
is now under question.
Mali's army-led goverment has expelled the
French ambassador and demanded the immediate
departure of both French and European forces.
On the streets, the mood among the government's
supporters is clear.
"If France wants to leave, it must do so immediately,
no question of four or six months.
"We don't need France.
France has been with us too long!
Get her out!"
Popular resentment against France has been
driven by its failure to stem the tide of
radical Islamic attacks in Mali.
The French troops' withdrawal now potentially
opens the door for talks between the government
and radical islamist forces it opposes.